[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec marie hélène
aubert maire de jouy en josas
bonjour je vous avez été élu aux
dernières élections municipales
mais vous étiez à l'apéritif la première
fois c'était en 2001 c'est ça 2001 p
2008 qui avait atteint voilà vous êtes
merci aux étiquettes
oui ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
indépendante des partis politiques
besoin sans étiquette c'est pas sans
conviction non c'est indépendant des
partis politiques ont d'ailleurs
l'impression que la fonction de maire
évidemment il ya des élections
politiques ou aux d'après qui a gagné la
voix de la gauche le centre etc
mais c'est une fonction qui dépasse les
clivages n'ont à oui biensur les gens
votent pour une personne dans une
municipalité voudrait pas pour une
étiquette sauf dans les grandes villes
peut être et encore donc vous avez été
élu assez facilement 1 66% des 66 % avec
une direction un peu particulier en
souviens c'était le début de la crise de
la colline alors joué le jeu a
évidemment tout le monde connaît ou
peut-être ne connais pas enfin il ya il
ya un personnage célèbre qui oberkampf
qui est le créateur de la toile de jouy
c'est ça qui a créé la célèbre
magnifique qui a été maire qui était le
premier maire de la ville oui oui oui
j'étais au canada à la fin du xviiie
siècle et donc qui a créé la manufacture
qui a atteint plus de 1200 employés à
l'époque c'était énorme
c'était un des premiers industriels de
france et puis la toile de jouy qui
aujourd'hui renommé dans le monde entier
très apprécié par les américains les
japonais est donc aujourd'hui un musée
qui devient presque trop petit leur
argent à angers mais la toile de jouy
elle se fabrique ou alors elle se
fabrique un peu partout on est en train
aujourd'hui d'essayer de protéger cette
marque toile de jouy parce qu'elle est
copié plagié
oui et donc aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est de
pouvoir en assurer la protection
donc il ya ce musée ne le disais combien
il est assez grand et pas assez grands
maintenant parce qu'aujourd'hui face à
la renommée de la toile de jouy lé
partout
il ya beaucoup de projets d'expositions
de donateurs qui veulent nous donner
leurs collections de collectionneurs qui
veut nous donner leurs collections et
puis aujourd'hui nous ambitionnons d'en
faire un écomusée même plus largement de
recréer de l'artisanat d'avoir un musée
ouvert sur les universités du plateau de
saclay pour faire un pôle ressource la
voile imprimé
voilà donc et puis amusé il s'ancre dans
le 21e siècle avec justement le le
numérique
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire est ce
que c'est le site qui attire le plus de
touristes de jean louis aubert il ya
beaucoup de choses qui attire les
touristes
il ya déjà quartier autrefois mais oui
ça c'était toutes les petites allées au
bout évidemment léon blum qui a fini sa
vie à jouer qui est mort en 1950 qui est
enterré à jouer et est qui et qui a
légué sa femme a légué la maison à la
ville de jouy en josas
donc nous en assurons la mémoire est une
association s'est créée pour en
perpétuer la vie et pour pouvoir
accueillir des publics et faire revivre
l'esprit de léon blum qui était un
humaniste avant d'être de l'élite
artistes invités rebond de 7,1 millions
aux politiques dire si tu de vie qui est
assez lié à la littérature jour je n'ai
vu que victor hugo venez y retrouver
juliette drouet oui ça c'est les petites
histoires d'alcôve c'est pas thibaudier
nous oui a vécu il y avait une école une
école très réputé l'école démons celle
qui a accueilli des jeunes qui sont
devenus plus tard des grands écrivains
comme modiano il ya aussi alors dans le
cerveau y albert calmette le oui blessé
l'homme l'inventeur du pcv qui est
enterré à jouer des centenaires
oui oui c'est au fond c'est 1500
habitants à papa oui oui c'est une ville
où il fait bon vivre ce que vous
privilégiez au fond l'environnement
c'est son nom oui ça bénéficie d'une
très grande attractivité puisqu'on est
seulement à 13 kilomètres de paris tout
près de personnes tout près de
versailles
à côté des grands pôles d'emplois que
son vélizy que sont saint quentin en
yvelines et puis et puis demain le
plateau de saclay et puis c'est dans un
petit bijou vous savez c'est la vallée
de la bièvre qui a été classé en l'an
2000 est donc très très protégé un
environnement exceptionnel voilà là
puisque vous voilez vallée de la bièvre
il veut dire ou de l'aviron va pouvoir
la revoir c'est ça oui on est on est
parti dans le faire des projets oui oui
ça fait c'est dans les tuyaux depuis un
moment déjà je démarre le mandat avec
cette réouverture de la bièvre qui était
canalisée en centre ville qu'on ne
voyait pas et qu'on remet au grand jour
avec un remuant de rage des berges
naturelles pour favoriser la
biodiversité pour prévenir les crues
et puis et puis c'est des sources de de
bien-être et de baisses de température
voilà c'est une grande chance une
rivière dans une ligne jaune c'est celui
ça va être quelque chose de magnifique
et bien oui il ya eu des gros employeurs
dans le secteur si l'inra non l'inra
1200 chercheur à l'inra 1200 chercher et
puis je sais aussi et je sais qu'on
allait me en à 1200 étudiants se sont
réduits mais il ya aussi l'excellence
scientifique vont jouer gros pôles de
recherche et de formation ingénieur
chose à souhait et d'où lé projet très
novateur
vous en parliez c'est suite au tas linux
c'est quoi total linux et quel est le
projet est haute à linux est une
entreprise qui depuis longtemps a joui
et puis qui était assez discrète et puis
qui est racheté un terrain la sortie de
l'a 86 pour y construire un data center
et un datacenter nouvelle génération
environnantes environnemental
exceptionnel puisque vous savez que les
datacenters des c'est ça consomme
énormément d'énergie énormément d'eau et
que c'est aujourd'hui un gros problème
pour pour la planète parce que on
utilise beaucoup de numérique on a
besoin de stocker ces données la 5g va
encore accentuer davantage ce besoin
stocker les données et donc ce problème
de court sa motion d'eau et consommation
d'électricité est un vrai problème
d'ici quelques dizaines d'années on aura
des gros des gros sujets et donc ce data
center va être autonome en énergie va
baigner dans l'huile au lieu de baigner
dans l'eau enfin me demandez pas les
détails techniques
voilà voilà ça va être extrêmement
révolutionnaire ne va pas être
consommateur ni d'énergie ni d'eau et
donc c'est une grande chance ça va
contribuer à la préservation de notre
planète
alors on parlait de la quelle était la
vie l'habitat de de jouy c'est plutôt
koidu des habitats individuels des
petits immeubles mais on a une ou deux
résidences un peu plus importantes qui
ont été construites dans les années 70
mais c'est surtout de l'habitat
individuel avec jet de couvrir un
vieillissement de notre population des
gens qui sont là depuis très longtemps
et qui vise donc ils peuvent quand on
habite juive on ne repart pas à moins
d'y être obligé vous même
mais non là on servait il ya 40 ans vous
avez des mes enfants restés et vous êtes
engagés dans la vie reste il que
pourquoi quel est le fondement de cet
engagement c'est de travailler pour les
autres de robin je crois que ça vient
naturellement vous savez quand vous avez
des enfants dans une école vous engagez
parents d'élèves engagés dans les
associations et puis naturellement il ya
le maire
deux moments qui vient vous chercher
parce que vous êtes actif dans la ville
et puis voilà c'est un engagement
c'est un engagement naturel je disais
vous avez été élu maire dans des
circonstances qui sont compliqués qui
sont la crise de l'aco vide commence à
un partout entre votre fonction parce
que c'est vrai que cela il faut c'est
compliqué celui des masques et a
déraillé hier c'est vrai la gestion de
la crise au niveau sanitaire a été
compliqué parce que c'est pas notre
premier métier de gérer ses affaires
sanitaires
ça a été compliqué aussi bien
psychologiquement parce que quand on est
maire on n'est pas n'est pas mère pour
être enfermé dans son bureau du maire
pour être sur le terrain on est maire
pour rencontrer ses habitants là c'est
plus compliqué tous les évènements été
annulée il ya plus ce côté positif du
mandat qui est de partager ensemble les
gestionnaires aujourd'hui est-ce que ça
altère le fil des finances publiques de
la ville
ah oui bien sûr ma la gestion de la
crise l'année dernière de toutes les
villes ont un peu impacté le paf abbas
étaient cent mille euros donc à evry
c'est cent mille euros deux mois sur
notre sur notre budget et puis je crois
que ça va être encore cette année un
voilier comment on fait pour ce club
eh bien on fait des économies ailleurs
fait trio rites et à la santé privés
devront de nouveau à non non non pas
d'augmentation d'impôts vous est dû
malgré ça vous êtes d'une mère heureuse
oui oui oui oui j'adore ce que je fais
j'adore j'adorerais pouvoir être au
contact mais électeurs alors j'espère
que ça va revenir
on fait tout pour que les gens souffrent
le moins possible de cette crise
sanitaire a joué en tout cas c'est que
les gens ils vivent le mieux possible
merci beaucoup m'aérer nobert donc merde
de jouy en josas vous est aussi
conseillère départementale et vice
président du conseil départemental
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]